Students across the land are wrapping up
annual state tests. For all the backlash
these tests spark, they exist mostly in
response to a sensible expectation that
parents know how their schools are doing.
We should neither abandon testing nor
ignore its problems, but ensure that it's
used responsibly.
Here are four thoughts on how to do just
that. First, reading and math scores can
go up or down for lots of reasons. Why
scores go up matters as much as whether
they do. Second, when a focus on reading
and math tests shifts time away from
other important learning, we need to
weigh the costs and benefits. Third,
reading and math tests capture only a
narrow slice of what schools are asked
to do. That matters. Fourth, today's state
tests don't provide meaningful immediate
feedback. It's hard to blame families for
doubting the value of tests which are
more useful for grading schools than for
educating kids. Look, testing is a
valuable tool, but like any tool, it's
only effective when it's used well.
How do you think we can better use
standardized tests? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.